the complaint of many citizens arrived
on her desk demanding action cases of
maladministration in the European
institutions come under scrutiny who
islands Emily O'Reilly the EU Ombudsman
reelected by plenary was a vast majority
the sewer to all the Ombudsman pulled
since its inception hazel Riley promises
greater transparency on major issues i
started doing investigations into for
example the transparency around the
european union and US trade negotiations
into the way that expert groups advise
the commission into a phenomenon known
as revolving doors where by senior
officials from the commission and other
institutions go into the private sector
and making sure that there aren't
conflicts there Emily O'Reilly is no
stranger she replaced the previous
Ombudsman who stepped down in 2013 last
year alone the Ombudsman dealt with 2420
complaints and helped more than 23,000
citizens through advice agencies and
information resources her mandate will
run until 2019 governance of Europe's
economy was at the heart of debate in
plenary implementation of the EU
stability and growth pact and the
so-called to pack and six pack measures
dealing with budget deficits in member
states it's well under way but Emmie
peas wanted measures to be reworked law
school girl estoy comiendo Rizzo novo k
let's pass academic Alicia Union whea
LuAnn alpha co buon qua sauce repeater
shamash this person MP machine extra
significance of eggs only one hang
smaller countries such as Greece Ireland
and Portugal have been making
significant efforts for several years
some mep s argue it's now down to the
bigger nations to follow suit delenda
sin vida al vinebox tomes close to
wicked the enshrinement FRG it is Bosma
hyundai linda italian fan cocooned here
moose decommissioned of yours organ does
the regular alpha d cousin landok
ellenton the european commission is
expected to put forward draft revision
in january and
p.s will be hot on the heels of the
proposal with their response the U is
coming to the aid of workers made
redundant due to the economic crisis tu
globalization adjustment fund is used to
help workers get back into a job and to
create more employment almost 26 million
euros is set to go to the three thousand
a train and the ATF france workers who
lost their jobs in 2013 nearly two
million will go to the 600 whirlpool
workers in italy and 1.25 million to
fiat employees and poland